[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sea otters
well we always take a a you know a break
in the summer i say break because we
work for most of it it's usually to
update things like software hardware in
the studio and we've been fortunate
enough to you know expand the space just
have a whole bunch of new office space
new hires which
has been far from easy with the
shortages for everything from from steel
to lumber
but aside from that you know taking dave
with me on this
this big fall tour that we're doing is
i mean i mean it's something i've never
done before you know venues
that are four five six thousand seats
and uh
i mean i'm incredibly grateful i'm
incredibly humbled i never ever want to
take it for granted
but you also realize that when you do
places
this size
uh
[Music]
you see it with a lot of people on here
it's very easy for it to
to go to your head
and and really
that can be that can be the death of you
it's uh
it's incredible to see uh all the people
to whom this means
so much crowder love landau absolutely
super happy to be here but for for
comedy um
in a venue that size sometimes it's
it's it's tough to know exactly what
really works
so on the break i thought it was really
important to
you know kind of go back to my
my roots and
perform a bunch of shows in in smaller
venues
um
just because it's it's it's more
conversational you know you're right up
close with people and uh
you you get to see what what really
works i love how you were all offended
and then clapped
i was like oh
you know while there's no doubt that
like doing six shows
on a weekend you know an hour and a half
each is is exhausting but it's
it's also i mean in some ways you prefer
it because you get to connect with
people directly i mean the people who
are
sitting there at the front tables for
example they're probably 20 or 30 feet
closer than the next closest people
in one of these one of these theaters or
half arenas and uh it allows you to
go back and forth a little more and
create something really special
you're saying what
freedom pimp okay thanks for adding that
to the show
[Applause]
you know i'm not your husband right like
i don't have to listen to your vote
[Applause]
remember what i said about women not
being funny right yeah
you have to live with that
[Applause]
as you're waking up to that every
morning you just turn over see your face
like the grudge freedom
just rising up like dune
freedom
you know everyone has their thing so i
certainly never want to complain i i
just always find myself incredibly
grateful but this this last year
it has been a tough one you know i
didn't really have the time that i
needed to recover from that surgery then
was in and out of the hospital because
of
the complications uh
and balancing
what i need to be doing health-wise with
the show that we do every day um
along with you know being on the road
doing change my minds and then of course
these these big venues
where we'll be doing you know really
just pure pure stand-up uh
it's a it's a tough balancing act
but it really is one
it's a challenge i'm looking forward to
and
my aim is
i think everyone here our aim is and i'm
really excited to
show people something they've never seen
before
this next year is
it's going to be different and
[Music]
i can definitely say with certainty
you haven't seen anything yet
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
you